الى لبنان حيث نقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصدر
امني قوله ان شخصين استشهدا واصيب خمسه
اخرون في غاره اسرائيليه استهدفت سياره في
بدله كفره جنوبي لبنان واضاف المصدر ان
مسيره اسرائيليه استهدفت السياره قرب حاجز
للجيش اللبناني وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان
مقاتلات اسرائيليه شنت عش غارات على بلدات
في جنوب لبنان فاستهدف بلده مركبه بسب
غارات ومحيط بلدتي طلو وكفر كلا بثلاث
غارات كما افاد مراسل الجزيره بانه بان
قصفا مدفعيا اخر استهدف محيط بلدات عيترون
ومارون الراس ويارونق يام وعيت الشعب وشيح
جنوبي البلاد من جهته اعلن حزب الله ان
مقاتليه استهدفوا سكنه برانيت الاسرائيليه
بالاسلحه الصاروخيه وحققوا اصابه مباشره
وافاد مراسل الجزيره باطلاق صاروخين من
جنوب لبنان باتجاه موقع اسرائيلي في مزارع
شبعه المحتله هذا واعلن حزب الله اللبناني
استشهاد احد مقاتليه في جنوب
[موسيقى]
لبنان من الناقوره جنوبي لبنان معنا مراسل
الجزيره جوني طانيوس ومن الجليل الاعلى
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري ابدا معك ج
هناك تطورات فيما يتعلق بالبيان الصادر
قبل قليل من حزب الله والذي قال باستشهاد
احد
عناصره في الواقع عبد القادر مما لا شك
فيه ان الهجوم الذي نفذت هذه المسيره
الاسرائيليه على سياره في بلده كفره اليوم
يحمل ابعادا اضافيه من التصعيد الاسرائيلي
تجاه لبنان وتجاه حزب الله تحديدا نحن
نتحدث عن غاره نفذتها مسيره اسرائيليه على
سياره في في بلده تبعد نحو 10 كيلومترات
عن المنطقه الحدوديه على مقربه من حاجز
للجيش اللبناني ما ادى الى استشهاد شخصين
واصابه اخرين بجروح وقبل بعض الوقت نعى
حزب الله احد عناصره الذي بحسب المعلومات
كان في داخل هذه السياره ليست هذه المره
الاولى التي تستهدف فيها السيارات
والاليات من قبل المسيرات
الاسرائيليه بات واضحا ان هناك نهجا
يعتمده الجانب الاسرائيلي لنح استهداف
مسؤولين في حزب الله وعناصر في حزب الله
من خلال المسيرات ومن خلال العبوات
الناسفه وحصل ذلك يوم امس عندما استهدفت
سياره من قبل مسيره اسرائيليه على مقربه
من مدينه سور في اي حال حزب الله ايضا رد
على ما سماه الاعتداء على المدنيين في
بلده كفرا واعلن قبل بعض الوقت انه استهدف
مستوطنه افيفيم بالاسلحه المناسبه ما ادى
الى اصابه احد المنازل ووقود من كانوا فيه
بين قتلى وجرحى كذلك اعلن حزب الله عن
تنفيذه ثلاث عمليات عسكريه اخرى ا كان
باتجاه مزارع شبعه او ثكنه بيراني وايضا
موقع حدب البستان بالاضافه طبعا الى هذه
الغارات التي ذكرتموها وهي غارات كانت
عنيفه ومكثفه باتجاه قر في القطاع الشرقي
والتي بحسب المعلومات ادت الى سقوط جرحى
والى اضرار كبيره في المنازل في مركبه وفي
بلده كفركلا جفاره ماذا عن الوضع وعن
بيانات الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى
الان قبل حوالي النصف ساعه اكدت هيئه البث
الاسرائيلي انه بالتاكيد كان هناك استهداف
لموقع افيفيم ولكن الذي تم توجيه صاروخ
مضاد للدروع اليه اصاب منزل ولكن دون
اصابات او اضرار حسب وصف هيئه البث ولكن
وفق البيان المحدث للجيش الاسرائيلي يقول
انه نفذ خلال الساعات ماضيه على الاقل
موجتين من الغارات اي من خلال الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه على منطقه مركبه اذا
التركيز اليوم كان على هذه البلده تحديدا
ووفق بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي هو يقول انه
يتم استهداف مواقع ومباني وبنى تحتيه
عسكريه تابعه لحزب الله وانه ايضا قام ب
تنفيذ غارات وقصف مدفعي اتجاه مواقع عده
في الجنوب اللبناني دون تح ديد هذه
المواقع في ساعات الصباح ايضا كان هناك
استهداف ل موقع عسكري يعرف ببراني ويضم
مقر الشمال عصبه الجليل ولكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يتطرق على الاطلاق الى هذه
الاستهدافات ولكنه فقط اشار انه لا يوجد
اصابات بالطبع عندما تم استهداف افيفيم او
برانيت او غيرها من هذه المواقع خلال هذا
النهار وايضا في مزارع شبعه لم تدوي
صافرات الانذار هذا يدل على ان حزب الله
استهدف هذا اليوم فقط من خلال الصواريخ
المضاده للدروع بمعنى رفع الوتيره ليس
بقذائف هاون او كاتيوشا وبالتالي لا
تستطيع الصواريخ المضاده او الاعتراضيه او
صافرات الانذار اعتراض هذه الصواريخ
وبالتالي هي تصيب الهدف الموجهه اليه ولكن
على الصعيد ايضا السياسي لازالت التصريحات
متصاعده شيئا فشيئا ما بين التلويح
بالتهديد وما بين الوعيد بمعنى انه اليوم
ضباط كبار في الجيش الاسرائيلي قالوا انه
يجب ان يكون هدنه لمده 48 ساعه ليومين لا
يكون فيها اطلاق نار من الجانب الاسرائيلي
وايضا من جانب حزب الله ان انتهى هذين
اليومين وقام حزب الله بالقصف فهذا معناه
انه سيكون هناك قصف عنيف جدا واعتبار
الجنوب اللبناني منطقه حرب حتى الان واضح
ان اسرائيل ت
مع الجنوب اللبناني وفق ما صدم به ايضا من
معلومات شيء اخير انه صدم من حجم البنى
والمواقع العسكريه التي تمكن حزب الله من
بنائها على مدار السنوات الماضيه جديري من
الجليل وانوس من النقور جنوب لبنان شكرا
جزيلا لكما